hey folks my name is jake and i'm here
with john luke and as of now
cyberpunk's 1.2 patch is now live
this is a huge patch john luke i don't
know if you've had a chance to look
through
all of those patch notes but it is
it's thick there's a lot there i don't
got all day man i got work to do i
yeah i tried looking a little bit over
my lunch break and i was like this is
too much we're gonna go over some of the
main points but rather than
go through the entire patch list explain
to you what's there we figured
the two of us are just going to play
some cyberpunk today i played a lot on
pc
john luke played a lot on ps4 and a
little bit on ps5 as well
and we're just going to share our
experience talk about some of the bigger
fixes
some things that still might need to be
fixed and whether or not you should play
cyberpunk 2077 now we'll do separate
evaluations more or less i'll talk about
pc jean-luc will talk about ps4 ps5
uh obviously these aren't official uh if
you want to check out the gamespot
review be sure to check that out
but anyway without further ado maybe we
should just go over some of the bigger
points
of what this patch does sean luke do you
want to kick it off so this is primarily
a bug fixing patch so they pretty much
just went through
and they fixed a lot of the bugs that
relate to
things like quest breaking um
npcs getting stuck uh
achievements not popping up uh items
uh like dialogue not uh properly playing
or repeating
ui getting stuck on the menus um
that one thing where you like t-pose out
of your car
uh i didn't see that when i played so i
think they fixed that one but
it's pretty much just fixing
things in the game that i think we're
preventing people from playing forward
or we're weird
stuff like you know items floating in
the world things like that
i did still have that issue there was an
instance where we gave someone an item
and the item was just floating in the
world and i was like huh
didn't seem as bad but yeah i guess
that's the other thing to point out
there was a lot to fix in cyberpunk
and even though this is a very lengthy
1.2 patch they've said that they have
another patch scheduled that will
address even more of the issues
but nonetheless this is still a pretty
big chunk some of the really big ones
are at least for me was changing the
icons on vehicles you can purchase
that we talked about this before but
that drove me kind of
crazy a little bit because i like having
the map look clear when i've done
all the quests but i still had all of
these exclamation points on the map
that were just telling me to go buy a
car now those are gone those are just
car symbols
that's great really small but it's one
of those small things that
for me personally just helps a little
bit you know
it it adds to it it feels good yeah
i i agree like that's maybe one of the
more significant of the like
i guess like actually changing the
structure as opposed to just like fixing
a bug
uh there are a couple other key ones
they've improved the handling on the
vehicles which
as we'll get into in a bit i didn't
really notice all that much
on console but maybe you can see it's a
little more significant
so even in the patch notes they
recommend not messing with it or no in
the
in the option settings they recommend if
you're using a controller you don't mess
with it so it's mostly for mouse and
keyboard
but we can talk about that later the
next thing though is the mini map
is still not fixed now that's something
i wanted to bring up
i guess it wasn't really broken but a
lot of people have requested a dynamic
mini map that zooms in and out the
faster you go
that hasn't been fixed that's something
i still notice it's hard to miss
when you miss turns constantly
especially when you're going really fast
and then the other big thing that cd
projekt red have got
have got a lot of criticism for are the
police response times now
they have delayed the response time i
tested out a little bit in the desert
because that was the one people were
most frustrated with because you'd
blow up a vehicle or shoot someone and
then ncpd would spawn behind you
now that still happens they still spawn
behind you
but there's it takes a longer amount of
time
first there's a drone that shows up and
then a
ncpd officer will spawn and then more
will spawn depending on how you interact
with that
it still bugs me because it doesn't it's
not a fix
it's just it feels like a band-aid over
the issue
and as you said like these updates
aren't
game-changing they're just fixes and
i think fixing that issue is a lot more
than just a quick patch fix
i feel like they'd have to rewrite a lot
of the ai but
i don't know i'm not a game designer but
what i can say
is that it it doesn't make a huge
difference in my opinion it's nice that
maybe they don't
charge you right away but still you know
you shoot them a couple times you get
three stars and
ncpd's will will surround you no matter
where you
are like i was out in the middle of the
desert and
still there uh yeah but anyway like i
said
i played on the pc version um i
you know i i did a couple missions i
explored the outskirts of night city i
explored all through night city
it ran pretty decently i didn't run into
many issues
however i originally played on pc i
didn't run
into many well i didn't run into many
uh uh moment-to-moment issues i ran to a
lot of bugs but the game itself ran
pretty decently back then seems to run
even better now even if it is just
nominally better it's still
it's slight but but but i noticed better
it feels less
duct taped together if that makes sense
uh and then beyond that
um didn't find any crashes didn't have
any crashes i played for about
three two and a half three hours didn't
have any of that obviously
that could still happen you know i
didn't play as much as i would have
liked
uh and then the steering sensitivity
which we talked about earlier
which you can adjust sensitivity
it's set at 100 which means your
vehicles will be the most sensitive
possible but you can lower that and as
the game
actually recommends you should only do
that if you're using mouse and keyboard
makes sense because when i did try to
drive a mouse and keyboard it was
difficult but even with those settings i
you know
driving with mouse and keyboard is still
difficult at the end of the day i'm
still gonna be
using a controller for that uh
but i guess that's a nice option to have
for folks who maybe don't have a
controller don't like using a controller
but you know it's not going to make
driving with a mouse and keyboard
fun necessarily yeah
but those are kind of my overall
thoughts i did run into some bugs still
there were some funny ones one example
was i was just driving around the
outskirts
and all of a sudden cars were just
flying into the sky
however there is there were two bugs i
ran into one was a
a quest bug where the character wouldn't
go to where they were supposed to go for
me to finish the quest
so that was kind of annoying and then
the other big one
was there is this uh there's a
oh i forgot what it's called a ncpd
scanner mission
that won't complete for me it says i
need to
fin it says i need to defeat all of the
hostiles in the area
there are none i've killed them all and
it still doesn't register that i've
beaten it
i like i i've reloaded that place so
many times it's been an issue for
a couple months now can't figure out why
it's not working this patch didn't fix
that
other than that it seems more stable on
pc uh
still still buggy but not as bad as it
used to be
i think there's like a reasonable amount
of jank and bugs that i think if it
shipped
like this it would have been a bit more
understandable
yeah uh and i would say that is
my experience with the ps5 version that
i gotta check out um
in my opinion the ps5 version at launch
was actually a pretty solid version of
the game
uh it ran decently well not as good as
the pc obviously but
it it was a functional version of the
game it's just that
the game was so buggy in other ways that
it was still kind of hard to recommend
now that most of the bugs have been
fixed my brief time playing the ps5
version
felt pretty good i was like yeah i could
see myself playing this version of the
game
i didn't encounter any any of the kind
of usual bugs that i
encountered when i tested the ps5
version back at launch
stuff like pop-in isn't really a big
deal it ran relatively smooth i would
say
if you have a ps5 and have the game and
you were waiting
to play it because of all the bugs now
might be a good time to hop into the
game you know
i can't get it on psn yet just can't get
on psn
you had to have bought it before so uh
but that brings us to
the base ps4 version which uh
i guess yeah all the bugs are or a lot
of the bugs are gone
but this isn't a performance patch and
the game
still runs like garbage it is
a horribly framy
terrible input lag uh menus
uh pop up and take forever to load in
it is in my opinion still very much
unplayable
and you know as we've said this patch
isn't claiming it was gonna make it
playable in that way
this is largely about just fixing uh you
know
like quest bugs and and other oddities
but
if you were looking at this expecting
like uh finally i can play it on my base
ps4
nope you're gonna have to wait for a
another patch that is
hopefully going to address the uh
specific performances of the ps4
although
in my opinion i kind of doubt
i i very much question if it'll even be
possible
to get this game to uh
to ever run well on a ps on a base
ps4 it's just it like because it's just
a loading issue like
you know like the game is just trying to
load in so much and like
it's so uh high demanding that i'm like
i just don't think a base ps4 could
possibly do it without doing some
serious work so
i'm sure cd projekt's gonna try we'll
definitely check it out uh
when you know whenever they put up the
next patch that tries to address those
issues but
if you have a base ps4 i would still not
recommend
playing it it's not there and uh
yeah maybe just maybe wait for the ps5
or
get it on pc at this point yeah i was
gonna say i think
the pc is i mean i think i recommend it
probably about as much as i did
when it launched uh obviously the less
bugs make it pretty nice but in terms of
optimization how it runs
it runs pretty well still
i think the bigger issue right now i
think
if you've got a pc and you're on the
fence whether or not you should play it
i think it more comes down to
is this the kind of game you want to
play
that's not really the point of this
video but uh
you know a lot of the issues that we had
and reviewers had
and just you know folks on reddit and
stuff had with this game
weren't simply the bugs and optimization
a lot of it had to do with
with with the way the story was told for
some people the the way the ai responds
to different things
so a lot of that kind of comes down to
where you fall there i would say if
if performance or optimization or
bugs was something you were worried
about bugs in particular like if you
didn't want to play when there was a lot
of bugs
then yeah now's the time to play on pc i
think you can probably get started
on it uh maybe take your time and then
the next optimization patch will come
out
or the next the next big patch will come
out later and
it'll be nothing but i don't think
you're gonna run into any huge
game breaking bugs if you just want to
play through on pc
yeah yeah that's pretty much my opinion
i mean i'm
this feels like a patch meant for people
who uh
put the game down because they were
waiting for it to just kind of be in a
more stable state
versus people who finish the game like
us
and are kind of waiting for those like
bigger meteor updates that maybe
do some more drastic changes for the
game and it's like ah now it's my chance
to go
play it again and see how it's improved
for those people
keep waiting uh i think you're not gonna
get anything for a while maybe not even
until
the next big uh dlc expansion whenever
that comes which is i think fall
is their current slate for that so if
you already beat the game and you were
hoping for something more substantial
you're just gonna have to wait a little
longer well anyway that's cyberpunk's
1.2 patch if you've got any questions
feel free to drop them in the comments
below or you can find us on twitter
and with that we will see you all next
time
[Music]
[Music]
you